la poursuite de ces négociations merci
la parole est un monsieur christophe
hiou
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
quand allez vous passer de la parole aux
actes samedi dernier le ni-ni a encore
frappé avec une énième manifestation
anti aéroport à nantes ni interdite ni
autorisée c'est certainement un cas de
jurisprudence en plein état d'urgence
encore l'enlisement libérer le pont de
cheviré axe principal de circulation à
nantes
c'était la moindre des choses mais
libérer l'emprise de notre dame des
landes occupé depuis des années ce
serait mieux
les représentants des centaines de
riverains de notre dame des landes
régulièrement harcelés racketter
intimidés ont été reçus vendredi dernier
par le nouveau président de la région
pays de la loire bruno retailleau
ses habitants sont marqués a usé par une
attente interminable interdit
d'emprunter des routes publiques fermées
légalement et de façon arbitraire à la
circulation par les opposants au projet
comme si la république pouvait reculer
capituler en rase campagne
l'été dernier le tribunal administratif
de nantes a tranché en faveur du projet
d'aéroport du grand ouest en épuisant
les derniers recours maintenant plus
rien ne se pose de démarrage des travaux
il donc plus que temps demain à cette
situation intolérable
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
une obligation de cohérence cette
décision en dernier ressort
je vous rappelle qu'en décembre 2014 il
ya plus d'un an déjà vous parliez de
passer à l'action après le jugement du
tribunal administratif
il est urgent nous l'avons déjà dit
plusieurs fois devant la représentation
nationale de rétablir la liberté de
circulation surtout de langue pour
l'emprise de notre dame des landes et
surtout d'expulser ceux qui troublent
l'ordre public d'en finir avec ce que ce
qui est devenu malheureusement le
symbole des blocages français c'est en
surface la plus grande zone de non droit
de france monsieur le premier ministre
allez vous enfin répondent aux français
qui demandent l'application la loi au
nom de l'intérêt général
merci la parole est à monsieur jean
marie le guen secrétaire d'état chargé
des relations avec le parlement
merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
christophe priou vous vous interrogez
tout d'abord sur les manifestations et
les débordements qui se sont déroulés
sur le pont de chevrier je veux
rapidement rappelé les conditions dans
lesquelles cette manifestation d'abord
s'est réalisée avec plus de 7000
personnes qui ont manifesté ce qui était
leur droit le plus légitime dans des
conditions qui étaient tout à fait
normal simplement à l'issue de ce
rassemblement plusieurs personnes n'ont
pas respecté l'engagement de dispersion
environ 250 individus sur les 7000 dont
je vous parlais qui à l'aide d'une
cinquantaine de tracteurs ont entrepris
de bloquer le pont chevrier et le préfet
après les discussions
évidemment demandant la dispersion de
cette manifestation et les sommations
d'usagé employés les forces de l'ordre
pour libérer le pont rétablir la
circulation comme cela devait se faire
cette intervention a été réalisé avec
discernement et la juste force
nécessaire cela a permis qu'il n'y ait
aucun blessé parmi les forces de leur
part ailleurs hier soir vers 18h30 à
savenay trois tracteurs agricoles foncé
délibérément sur les gendarmes du
peloton de surveillance et
d'intervention de la gendarmerie de
nantes occasionnant plusieurs blessés
parmi les forces de la gendarmerie
auquel le gouvernement veut apporter
tout son soutien
toute sa solidarité et les personnes est
évidemment ont été immédiatement
interpellé et placé en garde à vue
voilée monsieur le député nous sommes
donc tout à fait déterminés à faire
respecter l'ordre public qui garantit à
la fois la liberté
deux manifestations mais également face
à des fauteurs de trouble a nécessité de
rétablir l'ordre public lorsque cela est
nécessaire
enfin comme vous le savez le projet de
construction de l'aéroport de l'or suit
son cours comme juridiquement il est
possible et nécessaire de merci monsieur